i know that these people know a lot of  them they know  that men are men and women are women  and i don't understand the motivation or  the agenda  why are they trying to push it on to  young children what is the motivation  there changing society in terms of its  tax rates okay  changing the health care system it's a  pretty big deal but you know whatever  changing the way our energy sector works  as the environmentalists are trying to  do with the green new deal for instance  sure that's a big deal but if you can  redefine  human nature if you can actually get  everyone to believe or if not believe at  least say that a man is a woman and a  woman is a man  you can redefine anything and and i  think that's what's really at the heart  of this transgender obsession